las vegas now hosts mercedes martinez
she has had a residency on las vegas
radio for years and years and years
she's over at wix 941
helping us rise and shine with a dose of
positive stories
good morning mercedes good to see you
good morning you guys it is great to see
you too you might want to
grab some tissues for this first story
though i know it's rise and shine and
it's happy but it really is beautiful
take a look
it's awesome is it awesome
yes it is come here
that is four-year-old dylan and this was
the heartwarming moment that he heard
his mom's voice for the very
first time he quickly became overwhelmed
with emotion as we all are right now i
mean is someone cutting onions in here
or something what is going on
now this next story proves one man's
trash
compactor is another man's pool
ryan deloach calls it the swim pactor
and he's worked on it in his spare time
for the past
two and a half months saying it should
be finished soon
ryan had to teach himself to weld and
he's also painted it and installed
windows to make it look
like an aquarium if you didn't know me
personally you would probably think i'm
crazy but
anybody that knows me knows that if i
decide to do something
i make it happen so when i decided to do
this
there was no doubts whatsoever that's
why i put all this hard work in is so
that
i can lay back and watch my kids and my
wife enjoy a pool
that i've built that i can just enjoy
when it's all said and done that pool
it's gonna be
about four feet deep you you work with
what you've got
right why not i love how he says if you
don't know me personally
well uh we don't it's
the whole neighborhood's like who do you
think built the uh swimming pool out of
a trash bin it was probably right
yeah it was ryan that's who was because
i know him personally you know
yeah but you know what mercedes i've
seen homes that use different containers
and they
you know they move things around for
pools so i've seen that before i guess
um
just not so organically done
i don't know hey my dad made us a slip
and slide with garbage bags and wesson
oil when i was a kid
it was perfect so i wouldn't complain
yeah dish soap that was the move back in
the day too little slip and slide on
some trash bags
summertime fun summertime fun all right
mercedes thank you very much i will
catch you maybe we can all have a little
bit of a trash bin pool party
future what are you guys john's gonna
show up with trash bags mercedes
get ready for it well i know you
personally and you seem like the kind of
guy to do it
yeah thanks mercedes have a great
show bye guys